a seis meses del inicio de la guerra
logró rusia su intención de amortiguar
el fortalecimiento de la otan o logró el
efecto contrario
bueno ha logrado el efecto contrario
pero bajo el paraguas de eeuu
el sueño que tuvimos en europa de tener
un ejército solo europeo e independiente
de la otan pues ha fracasado
evidentemente y ahora tenemos que volver
a un mensaje inicial de una otan más
fuerte siempre y cuando tengamos el
apoyo en este caso de estados unidos y
de la gran bretaña que ya no está dentro
de la unión europea ha conseguido la
unión de la unión europea si ha
conseguido revivificar la otan también y
por tanto se puede decir que a nivel
geoestratégico sí bien putin se ha
convertido en un gran enemigo también
está perdiendo fuerza en lo que era el
control parece y luego la manera de las
zonas más cercanas a europa como se
encuentra occidente hoy en materia de
seguridad colectiva
occidentes del punto de vista de
cooperación policial se encuentra en el
punto vista cooperación militar estamos
a medio camino de lo que sería una breve
cooperación puesto que aún prima los
intereses individuales de los países
respecto al interés colectivo de la
defensa de brión europea y tiene que ser
una vez más estados unidos.el que nos
den el grado de cohesión la otan para
poder conseguir esa unificación pero
estamos a muy a un largo distancia aún
para poder saber si conseguiremos lo
conseguiremos esa unificación o esa
unión militar como es deseable señor
coche sigue la otan representando una
amenaza para rusia
desde punto de vista occidental la otan
no es una amenaza para rusia el punto de
vista del
pensamiento eslavo del pensamiento de
rusia si es una amenaza dado que
sistemáticamente la otan sigue
obteniendo información obteniendo el
país se quieren alinearse primera unión
europea y luego para tener un paraguas
de seguridad a la otan y eso aunque
nosotros no lo vemos como una amenaza
rusia ve como una amenaza y obra en
consecuencia podemos no estar de acuerdo
con sus acciones pero hemos de entender
que para el sur geopolítica está
amenazada por todo el conjunto de países
que no agraden antes más un país el
tapón porque la manera de fronterizo de
sin cinturón de seguridad nacional lo
llama la llama putin y ahora son
miembros de la otan esto a él le sienta
mal le sienta que es una amenaza y
aunque realmente la otan no sea una
amenaza porque no pretende ningún tipo
de agresión hacia rusia pues bueno rusia
lo ve como un ataque a sus intereses
geopolíticos a medio largo plazo a
propósito de esto que usted menciona qué
significado tendría la otan ahora ante
una eventual adhesión de suecia y
finlandia países que se habían mantenido
neutrales durante todo este tiempo
eso es un peligro muy grande es una
amenaza muy grande para rusia es una
provocación a mi modo de ver para rusia
estás maneras en la unión de estos
países bálticos se va a hacer una manera
diferente a cómo se está pensando por
ejemplo el caso de suecia se comprometen
a no tener nunca armamento nuclear para
obtener nunca bases
constantes y permanentes en el suelo en
su suelo de la otan y cualquier
armamento o cualquier tropa de la otra
eventualmente entrar en suecia estaría
siempre bajo mandato sueco y nunca
bajaban a toda la otan por tanto es una
inmunes un poco especial el caso de
finlandia pues bueno no se sabe que es
un lleva 30 años preparándose para un
conflicto con rusia y bueno el putt y me
ha dicho que no se quedará quieto pero
no ha dicho aún lo que va a hacer por
tanto veremos más adelante cuáles son
las consecuencias